my skin is not a threat
[Music]
it's funny how the world has different
time zones
how it could be saturday on this side of
the world and friday somewhere else
yes somehow the united states of america
is stuck in 1920.
that was a hundred years ago
[Music]
yet we're still fighting for our lives
for are placed here
[Music]
what did we ever do to make them hate us
so much
i know for a fact they love our culture
they love to steal our braids the way we
talk
anything we call ours but when it's that
one white
bad cop and that one innocent black
person
that black person fears for their life
this is the world we live in
see when i was younger teachers used to
ask kids what they wanted to be when
they grew up
some kids said famous i was one of those
kids
but now i changed my answer the thing i
want to be when i grow up
is alive
how do i know that i'm going to make it
out alive if i'm suspicious doing
nothing
if i'm suspicious when i'm at my own
house sleeping in my own bed
why am i suspicious because i could have
sworn from one to three i was the cutest
thing
but when did i stop being cute and
started being scary
am i scary if i have a black hoodie am i
scary if i wear a backpack
am i scary if i do nothing
am i scary does my dad scare you
does my mom scare you does my etsy scare
you
because let me tell you something we are
not scary
ahmad aubrey brianna taylor george floyd
tamir wright donald trey hammer michael
brown eric garner john crawford
ezell ford walters stephen demarco
tony robbins miles hall jamie johnson
rose stefan clark jacob blake
say their names you will earn my respect
when i don't have to fear from my life
or anybody else's
until then my respect will not come for
free
black lives matter
you